joining us now the chairman of the house
Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan and
Committee Member Matt Gates of Florida
thank you both
it doesn't surprise me that not a single
Democrat showed up they have been
telling us now for over two years that
the border secure Matt Gates asked the
question as mayor mayorcus lied to us
well every time he says the border is
secure we see with our own eyes that
he's lying to us
yeah if your policies were the reason
for 5 million illegal migrants coming
across our border and all the fentanyl
that's caused so much harm to countless
communities I don't think I would show
up either and understand this was done
intentionally from day one on day one
Joe Biden said no more wall no more
remain in Mexico no more deportation and
as a result of that we got all those
facts and figures you just cited Sean
but what we also got today what we heard
from people here in Yuma is how it
overwhelmed their school system their
hospital system their First Responders
their law enforcements border patrol the
cost to the folks here on the border and
across our border and maybe most
importantly now that's coming across the
country it's coming to Florida it's
coming to Ohio it's coming to New York
City even mayor Eric Adams said they
can't take anymore that's why this is so
serious and that's why we got to change
things and pass legislation out of our
committee and out of the house which we
plan to do and Matt Gates you you asked
the right question you know are did male
orcas lie to us but it's not just him
it's Joe Biden it's Kamala Harris it's
the entire Administration they keep
telling us the border is secure and our
eyes tell us something very differently
yeah tens of illegal immigrants show up
in Martha's Vineyard and they go crazy
as if they're being overwhelmed yet here
in Yuma Arizona we see a community on
the front lines of an invasion and
American babies in their most frail
moments in their first days and hours
are being crowded out of neonatal
intensive care units by migrants here's
the math on that Sean one in four
pregnancies from these illegal aliens is
presenting the need for NICU care
there's only 20 NICU beds in the
community here in Yuma and so American
babies from taxpayers right here folks
who are legally in our country sometimes
they have to go 170 miles away and if
you imagine that pain here it's coming
to a neighborhood near you because this
millions of additional people in our
country it absolutely affects the
culture and affects the competition over
limited resources well we have a battle
coming up and the Joe Biden the
Democrats are going to need the majority
House Republicans to get an increase in
the debt ceiling certainly I think most
conservatives Jim Jordan would want
something about fiscal responsibility
tied to any increase in the debt ceiling
can you also tie secure borders uh in
any agreement if they want that set
ceiling raised
we have to look at some place where some
must pass legislation where we can do it
I think that's probably more appropriate
on the appropriation bills which come up
in September but we have to be willing
to fight because we saw over the last
two days just how serious it is and as
Matt said it's going to come to all
parts of the country when you got that
volume of people that number of people
it's coming over so yeah we got to be
willing to fight because Joe Biden's not
going to just suddenly see to see the
light and do the right thing so it's
going to be up to us to fight all right
Jim Jordan and Matt Cates on the house
Judiciary Committee thank you for going
to the Border hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else